grades are important for students
because they can affect admission to
further studies employment opportunities
and also student benefits so students
have a right to a fair conversion of the
grades they've obtained during a period
of study abroad European higher
education systems have different grading
scales with a different range of passing
rates to make a different grading
cultures transparent we need a
statistical approach in practice what we
need to do is producing a grading table
for each degree course within a specific
subject area and this is not difficult
we take all the grades awarded in degree
course over a three-year period and
calculate the statistical distribution
for all of them including percentages
and cumulative percentages all
institutions should develop their
grading tables for all degree courses
and use them for the purpose of
transparency of the grading culture
behind them and also for the conversion
of grades for students involved in
mobility skills so let's say you're a
student of the University of Rome and
you studied in the University of Paris
based on the cumulative percentages 12
that you were awarded at the University
of Paris will correspond to the ranges
between 27 and 28 at the University of
Rome the University of Rome should
decide in advance whether to assign
minimum average or maximum grade to all
students within all ranges if average is
used 12 would be converted to 27 but if
maximum is used 12 would be converted to
28 even in cases when non numeric rates
are being given cumulative percentages
help building grading scales let's say
you're a Belgian student studying in
Austria and receiving the great goods
this grade would be converted into a 13
at your home University in
on the other hand if an Austrian student
studies in Belgium and receives the
great eleven this would be converted
into the great satisfactory it's a home
University in Austria in these examples
both institutions decide to use the
average when applying the great
conversion it is important for students
to inform themselves before the
departure on how the grades they receive
at the host institution will be
converted into the local system to
conclude we could say that through the
use of grading tables all grades could
be converted in a transparent and fair
way for all cases of students mobility